[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur
l'ensemble de vos chaînes régionales et
locales voici tout de suite les titres
de l'actualité alors que le gouvernement
souhaite que 20 millions de français
aient reçu leur dose de rappel d'ici
noël les pharmacies sont mises à
contribution comme vous allez le voir
dans un reportage à nîmes de nos
confrères devient occitanie il se peut
qu'en cette fin d'année vous ayez
commander vos cadeaux sur internet mais
êtes-vous certain qu'il ne s'agisse pas
plus de contrefaçons la chef
divisionnaire des douanes à toulouse
nous donne quelques astuces pour
distinguer le vrai du faux un sujet à
suivre de la dépêche du midi dans ce
journal également nous irons au moment
où des personnes sans abri ont trouvé un
toit grâce à l'association bureau du
coeur une belle histoire que nous
rencontrons nos confrères de lmtv sarthe
enfin nicolas guillet le rédacteur en
chef de ces offres le nouveau magazine
politique sera l'invité de ce journal
dans un instant
voilà comme je vous le disais il ya un
instant dans les titres le gouvernement
a fixé l'objectif de vacciner 20
millions de français contre la copie de
19 avec une dose de rappel vous le savez
avant noël or pour atteindre cet
objectif un arrêté daté du 12 décembre a
été publié et cherche à inciter les
femmes à six a proposé des créneaux de
vaccination le dimanche lors hicham erla
devient occitanie s'est rendu dans l'une
d'elles à nîmes pour voir comment la
vaccination s'organise regardez
malgré la réouverture des vaccinodromes
le carnet de rendez-vous ne désemplit
pas dans les pharmacies dans cette
officine nîmoise entre 20 et 30 patients
reçoivent une dose chaque jour carlsbad
jcall je comprends dans la voiture ou le
bugey d'aller à l'hôpital
l'habitat 200 m même pas donc c'est
centre-ville c'est très agréable et ce
n'est pas seulement la proximité qui
motivent le choix des patients certains
bouts de les centres de vaccination qui
réserve le finder pour les moins de 30
ans d'après une directive du ministère
de la santé les pharmacies elle continue
d'en administrer sans condition d'âge
alors les listes d'attentes commence à
se remplir environ 300 personnes
attendues fighter il vous le disent
qu'ils viennent justement spécialement
pour le fun oui spéciales et oui oui oui
parce qu'ensemble de vaccination ils
proposaient moderne
et certaines personnes ne veulent que du
finder alors que c'est lui même qui sont
les mêmes les mêmes vaccins sont des
vaccins ahrens le même type de vaccin et
pour accélérer la campagne de
vaccination le ministre de la santé
propose d'ouvrir les pharmacies le
dimanche une proposition refusée par
cette pharmacie par manque de temps et
de personnel
qui dit qu'on vide dit masque bien
entendu et l'importance de les recycler
pour éviter la pollution et la
propagation du virus une nécessité bien
comprise par la ville de limoges qui a
été récompensé pour sa campagne de
recyclage en nouvelles aquitaine
explication de la chaîne sur place 7 à
limoges la ville de limoges vient d'être
distingué lors du rendez vous national
de la communication publique capcom pour
sa campagne consacré au recyclage des
masques chirurgicaux que nous portons
tous cesc abandonné c'est moche il lui
faudrait quatre cent cinquante ans pour
se recycler le jeter à la poubelle c'est
un début
on peut faire mieux la démarche est
parti en fait du fait qu'on était tous
agents municipaux contraint de porter un
masque dans l'exercice de nos fonctions
à la demande de monsieur le maire que la
commande publique a contacté une société
qui procède au recyclage de ces masques
puis un savoir faire il ya un brevet la
vue sur le passage de la matière on va
dire textile textiles plastiques en
matière plastique injectables dans nos
ateliers les masques devienne un kit
règle est claire et rapporte la première
démarche a été de mettre en place une
signalétique les bacs ont été installés
au sein de tous les équipements
principaux et plus de supports
classiques les réseaux sociaux jouent un
rôle déterminant dans l'opération ça
fait boule de neige immédiatement il ya
des points de collecte de partout y
compris dans certains centres
commerciaux comme le centre
saint-martial mais aussi chez certains
commerçants ça a démarré un soir à 19
heures on a diffusé le visuel et le
président de la chambre de commerce a
réagi sur facebook en nous disant mais
c'est génial cette opération je veux en
être c'est là où l opération de
communication fonctionne bien parce
qu'on arrive à embarquer avec nous à un
nombre maximum de parts en plus des
supports de communication de la ville
l'affichage magazine mensuel télévision
locale l'initiative a bénéficié d'une
bonne couverture presse journaux radios
et télés c'est un succès il faut
continuer il faut que nous avions
collecté 500 mille masques au total nous
en sommes à 300 mille masques collectées
qui me permettent déjà de district mais
si c'est un cercle vertueux et qui
fonctionne en tâche d'huile et en réseau
nous donnons l'exemple et ça c'est un
bordel initialement 90 points de
collecte était prévu grâce à la
dynamique engagée et aux partenaires il
ya aujourd'hui plus de 200 points de
collecte en ville des kits seront à
nouveaux produits ainsi que des cintres
des pousses tube
voilà il se peut que vous fassiez partie
des 41 millions de français qui font
leurs achats sur internet un chiffre qui
ne cesse d'augmenter chaque année mais
comme je vous le disais en titre méfiez
vous des contrefaçons sandrine
coulangeon chef divisionnaire des
douanes de toulouse nous met en garde et
donne à agnès grimaldi de la dépêche du
midi quelques petits conseils pour
éviter les mauvaises surprises écouter
le consommateur doit être averti doit
être un citoyen averti quand vous
commandez sur internet commande est
toujours sur le site sur des sites
dirait qu'ils ont pignon sur rue le prix
également
peut vous alerter un prix très faible
peut laisser augurer d'une qualité
médiocre
également la présentation de l'article
voyez ces petits indices ont fait que le
consommateur doit être alerté
voilà dans ce journal nous restons le
sud ouest avec près de 3,8 millions de
français qui vivent dans un désert
médical
en novembre dernier une cinquantaine de
députés déposait une proposition de loi
dont une des mesures consistaient à
obliger les nouveaux diplômés a exercé
pendant trois ans dans un désert médical
en attendant voilà six ans que sainte
terre en gironde peine à trouver un
généraliste comme a pu le constater sur
place franck poireau de télé7 la chaîne
du groupe sud ouest regardez une
banderole en bord de route l'annoncent
la commune de sainte terre dans le
saint-émilionnais recherche depuis six
ans maintenant à médecins généralistes
elle a tout essayé voie de presse
publicité internet réseaux sociaux pour
faire connaître son besoin rien n'y fait
le cabinet médical appartenant à la
municipalité reste désespérément vide de
toute activité les habitants doivent se
rend à castillon libourne ou dans les
communes limitrophes pour une simple
consultation médicale chantal ruth et
conseillère municipale depuis plus de
six ans elle suit ce dossier cette
commune rurale de 1800 habitants comme
d'autres en france est confrontée à un
problème pour susciter l'intérêt des
médecins notamment les plus jeunes la
peur de l'isolément de la solitude du
praticien face à une charge de travail
qui s'annonce soutenue et bien les
médecins ne veulent pas s'installer
apparemment tout seul ça leur fait un
peu peur et après on est loin de la
ville y en a qui veulent pas non plus
installé en campagne les candidatures ne
se bousculent pas pour reprendre ce
local équipé d'un appartement à l'étagé
pourtant la commune est loin d'être un
désert médical par moins de 27
professionnels de santé y sont
représentés des dentistes et
kinésithérapeutes un pharmacien etc face
aux nombreuses tentatives avortées pour
faire venir un médecin à saint père la
mère a même envisagé un moment d'en
recruter un an le salarié tenais pour
une telle que la nôtre nos finances ne
le permettent pas malheureusement face à
cette multitude des chèques la commune a
donc choisi de prendre le problème à
l'envers en consultant l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé de son
territoire l'idée de les mettre tous en
lien les uns avec les autres pour
montrer un éventuel candidat médecins
généralistes qu'il ne sera pas seul
un médecin habitants sur la commune mais
travaillant l'extérieur se propose même
d'accompagner un interne qui viendraient
posé ses valises ici elle nous propose
de commencer en fait à travailler sur la
commune et de devenir maître de stage
pour pouvoir accueillir des internes sur
la commune éventuellement puisque nous
avons la chance d'avoir en plus un
cabinet médical équipé d'un appartement
laitages la mairie espère pouvoir
débloquer cette situation prochainement
en attirant un interne dans son cabinet
médical une première phase qui pourrait
faire boule de neige pour attirer
d'autres professionnels de santé la
mairie souhaite d'ailleurs réhabiliter
l'ancien presbytère en centre de soins à
moyen terme pour le mettre à disposition
de ces professionnels de santé en plus
du généraliste désespérément cherché la
mairie souhaite une sage-femme et un
radiologue puis s'installer ici à
l'avenir voilà une idée simple mettre à
disposition et bureaux vides de nuit à
des personnes dans le besoin je vous en
parlais en titre c'est l'idée de
l'association bureau du coeur créés en
2018 à nantes qui a fait des petits
d'ailleurs on vous emmène donc au mans
avec anthony python de lmtv sarthe où
une dizaine de personnes en difficulté
ont été mises à l'abri grâce à cette
initiative
le jour cette chambre sert à la
formation d'étudiants en hôtellerie la
nuit elle accueille franck
il y a encore dix jours il dormait dans
une tente près de la gare du mans avec
cet hébergement provisoire il commence à
rebondir
je suis plus en forme diable j'ai la
chance déjà mes papiers s'avance tout
bas puis j'y retrouve un petit peu de
boulot tout doucement et puis c'est ce
qu'il fallait parce que l'on n'a pas de
force qu'on veut travailler tout ça
voilà on n'a pas la tête pour sow zip
c'est pas trés me dont la voilà c'est
pour ça que j'ai la chance de saulcy
pilon profil pour avancer comme franck
une autre personne est hébergée chaque
nuit dans ce lycée professionnel
l'établissement fait partie des membres
des bureaux du coeur une association qui
veut ouvrir les entreprises aux
personnes à la rue les soirs et les
week-ends nous fait de
l'hôtellerie-restauration et jc champ
d'application et fonctionne toute
l'année pour les cours mais à partir de
17h30 elles sont libres alors pourquoi
pas accueillir des gens qui en ont
besoin depuis septembre une dizaine de
personnes ont ainsi été mises à l'abri
dans plusieurs entreprises du mans grâce
à l'action des bureaux du coeur sur les
dix personnes l'a8 travailler ni dormait
soit dans leur voiture soit entente ou
sont en squat mais la plupart travaillé
et pour ceux qui travaillaient pas ils
sont aujourd'hui l'exemple de de franck
qui est ici il a un boulot aujourd'hui
il travaille aujourd'hui grâce au fait
d'avoir un
un logement
au delà de l'hébergement un parcours
d'accompagnement social est aussi mis en
place pour les bénéficiaires donc
d'autres associations interviennent
alors comme tarmac où la croix rouge
voilà il est encore temps pour ceux qui
sont en retard d'aller acheter leur
sapin de noël luca ruch lui de 8 mont
blanc qui a rencontré marilyn blanc
éleveuse de sapins à vallière sûr fier
en haute savoie a constaté qu'elle était
très heureuse d'avoir reçu le label
savoie-mont-blanc excellence qui
récompense le travail des entreprises
localement regardez ce reportage
qu'il trône illumine fièrement la place
du village où votre salon le sapin de
noël est une tradition très ancrée dans
nos ménages mais avant de le décorer il
faut le choisir fraîchement coupés et
cela est possible à la sapinière blanc
de vallières sur fier
cette entreprise familiale vieille de 40
ans détient 10 hectares rempli de sapins
et d'épicéas la production y est
raisonné à taille humaine ce qui
convainc bon nombre d'acheteurs locaux
parce que vous allez mettre sur un
croisillon difficile de
devoir la différence avec d'autres
produits puisque nous on les prend ici
mais enfin nous on a quand même par
rapport à nos amis à la maison on voit
que certains tiennent très longtemps
dans la maison même avec de la
température et cette année grande
nouveauté cette sapinière comme six
autres du coin bénéficie du label
savoie-mont-blanc excellence qui
récompense la qualité du travail de ces
entreprises locales ainsi chaque sapin
est doté d'une étiquette rouge
explicative un petit plus non
négligeable pour ces éleveurs
produits que les consommateurs adorent
dans le sens où il est coupé très
fraîchement par rapport aux produits
qu'on veut travailler dans des
supermarchés et
en plus pour la petite anecdote ils sont
désherber par des moutons qui
évite de mettre des produits phyto et
donc les gens en étaient conscients mais
ils ont pas forcément l'information de
savoir où est ce qu'ils peuvent les
trouver donc ce label est une
opportunité et une chance pour nous avec
cet agrément la sapinière blanc espère
cette année vendre un tiers de sapins en
plus un chiffre qu'il faudra atteindre
avant le 24 décembre au soir date du
réveillon de noël
voilà après les sapin les cadeaux bien
sûr si vous ne savez pas quoi offrir à
votre petit neveu ou votre petite nièce
voici les tendances jouer de cette année
par antoine beunaiche responsable de
magasin accords berra en haute corse au
micro d'albane gingembre et de pierre
pasqualini de télé pas aisé sur place
évidemment il ya des tendances qui se
dégagent c'est dû notamment la sortie de
différents films qui ont été reportés
avec avec le convie donc toutes ces
sorties de films font que la licence
marche beaucoup cette année on a
beaucoup de
deux jeux en bois que justement il made
in france des personnes qui vont
rechercher ce genre de produits king
jouet c'est de vraiment ciblé sur ces
produits là donc on sait que
malheureusement 60% à peu près de nos
produits viennent d'asie mais on essaie
de plus en plus d'aller vers des
produits made in france qui sont
signalés en magasin vous allez pouvoir
le voir des produits aussi qui qui sont
plus éco responsable et on va avoir des
jouets comme ça qu'ils vont être un peu
tendance je pense que beaucoup de gens
qui se sensibilisent à ce genre de sujet
voilà et puis on sera un peu plus haut
dans les bouches-du-rhône
connaissez-vous saint chamas la commune
de 8500 habitants a acquis une petite
notoriété grâce à sa crèche de plus de
120 m² d'ailleurs qui a été créée par
jean codo est un retraité de 78 ans cet
amoureux de la provence nous fait faire
le tour du propriétaire son village
qu'il a commencé à construire il y a dix
huit ans un reportage d'arthur souris
basse de la provence sur place là vous
avez aimé la mode vous avez les
bugadières et femmes qui font la lessive
les rendant chez les lie foule le réseau
aux pieds et jambes je me demande
pourquoi vous faites ça et puis ça
d'abord pour mon plaisir parce que s'il
fallait que je sois contraint de faire
ça pour être un peu maso ce que je fais
là c'est pour rendre hommage aux gens
d'avant les anciens leur travail qui
était dur le travail de la terre ces
gens là il travaillait il s'occupe pas
de savoir s'il y allait avoir des
vacances ou pas il travaillait pour
nourrir leur famille et puis le 11
décembre dernier diane l'air miss ile de
france et est élue miss france 2022
comment l'ignorer à ses côtés floriane
bascou miss martinique et première
dauphine alwyn course il devient atv
martinique et alain l'attendre à la
sortie de l'avion regarder
après une courte nuit et plus de 300 km
la première dauphine de miss france est
fier de nous montrer sa nouvelle écharpe
la jeune l'amandinoise retrouve ses deux
frères et ses parents après un mois
intense de préparation aux concours et
ensemble ils revivent son élection
les parents
c'est la première fois que je revois ces
images puisque j'ai pas encore eu le
temps de me poser là je regarde un peu
en famille ça me fait plaisir les
parents et les frères présents lors de
la cérémonie sont ravis de voir floriane
termini devant les 27 autres candidates
présentent aux concours ce qui était
vraiment important pour moi c'est que
qu'elle ressorte avec le moment une
expérience positive avant sur scène ben
ça m'a rendu vraiment fier on a tout de
suite et j'ai essayé de chercher son
regard quand elle est arrivée sur scène
justement pour vidéo qu'on était là
quand la soutenait qu on était avec elle
on a vraiment cru
qu'ils allaient floriane moi j'ai voté
je suis même pas dormir ouais je
vraiment voyais comme facture
est bon pour l ol à bord il pour nous
l'équipe de floriane repas est elle
aussi satisfaite du travail accompli
puisque miss martinique repart de caen
avec le vote du coeur des français je
pense que tous leurs marques et comment
floriana à transcender la scène sont
qu'à 3 comme on dit sur scène je pense
que ça a vraiment marqué
cette année s'annonce encore riche en
événements pour floriane puisqu'en tant
que première dauphine elle participera à
une autre élection internationale mais
dont ceux pris part dans l'optique de
miss monde on a encore une bonne secrète
on a encore des ambitions fortes on a
des visions grande et l'organisation
miss martinique va encore donner toute
l'amplitude de ce travail revendre
content de parler d'elle parce qu'on ne
reste pas sur cette fin en attendant de
voir notre miss à l'international
floriane va pouvoir profiter encore un
peu de ses parents dans l'hexagone avant
de revenir après les fêtes sur son île
natale
voilà puis dans ce gîte et on reste dans
les couronnes après les miss leroy et
vous allez voir pas n'importe lequel
puisqu'il s'agit de louis xiv on se rend
au château de versailles pour ces fêtes
de fin d'année où les visiteurs se
retrouvent projetés vous allez le voir
dans le passé une féerie garanties comme
vous allez le voir dans ce reportage de
tv 78 à la chaîne des yvelines
au château de versailles la magie de
noël règne en maître pour les fêtes de
fin d'année louis xiv invite les
visiteurs à vivre des moments de danse
et de musique
[Musique]
picard est une occasion très
particulière et renouvelle tous les ans
du moment des fêtes de
la chasse aux visiteurs
se laisser éblouir par du spectacle
mise en scène
mise en espace
[Musique]
à l'image des fêtes du roi soleil qui
ont organisé trois fois par semaine la
visite spectacle a été pensé par deux
compagnies est un ensemble
[Musique]
sur des comédiens dans la cale à des
classes
dans ce
quelle position
ensuite ils sont
dans la galerie des batailles
alors cinq séances sont organisées dans
une déambulation dans les salles les
plus célèbres du château tout à fait
plaisant est différent
les uns les autres
[Musique]
c'était charmant à
c'était
mais ce que j'aime vraiment
venir le soir
l'ineris
et parce que c'est fait ne serait rien
sans son père noël il vient lui aussi de
l'époque baroque avant de s'éclipser
pour aller faire sa tournée
voilà et puis dans ce journal des images
de l'ancien temps je veux dire du temps
où les boîtes de nuit était encore
ouverte c'était donc la semaine dernière
tiens il a sonné denis lequel de vos
jeux tv ont immortalisé ces toutes
dernières heures dans un club à charmes
comme vous êtes pouvoir le voir
danser faire la fête jusqu'au bout de la
nuit une dernière fois c'était en
quelques sortes un baroud d'honneur ce
mercredi soir dans cette discothèque à
charmes avant que les portes ne se
referment pour quatre semaines minimum
le couperet en effet une nouvelle fois
tombé sur le monde de la nuit avec
l'annoncé il ya quelques jours par le
premier ministre jean castex de
nouvelles mesures restrictives pour
tenter de contrer la cinquième vague de
l'épidémie parmi elles la fermeture une
nouvelle fois encore des boîtes de nuit
et au moins jusqu'au 7 janvier prochain
on est conscient qu'il ya une cinquième
muraille bien sûr donc là dessus c'est
indéniable et après c'est toujours les
discothèques qui trinquent en premier on
rappelle quand même qu'il ya eu quatre
vagues de co vide et que les
discothèques été fermés
monsieur est venu faire une passation
ça
m
[Musique]
on se souvient qu'en juillet dernier
après 16 mois de fermeture des
établissements nocturnes en france celui
de charme avait pu rouvrir pour refermer
provisoirement une dizaine de jours plus
tard on y avait en effet détecté un
cluster de 44 personnes ce mercredi à
l'entrée il fallait montrer patte
blanche pièce d'identité parce
sanitaires et cahiers de rappel était de
rigueur le port du masque était
obligatoire lui aussi sur la piste mais
pas toujours respectée malgré les
multiples rappels à l'ordre du dj du
gérant et d'un service de sécurité
renforcé
depuis sa réouverture la discothèque ne
désemplissait pas réalisant de très bons
chiffres d'affaires cette nouvelle
fermeture c'est donc un coup dur ce
mercredi soir on a comptabilisé tout de
même 1250 deux entrées moins qu un
week-end normal à 2000 personnes mais le
double de ce qu'espérait la direction
décembre moins festif par excellence et
pour parler argent le plus important de
l'année avec des week-ends à cent mille
euros de recettes les discothèques
feront l'objet d'un nouvel
accompagnement financier par l'état
bonjour nicolas à guérir vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de ces of un nouveau
magazine politique qu'on voit sur cet
écran alors pourquoi notre groupe le
groupe prévoir le média a décidé de
lancer un nouveau magazine politique un
magazine d'investigation
bonjour civile c'est un peu une
conjonction de plusieurs facteurs qui
nous ont donné cette idée
d'abord effectivement comme vous le dis
que la période est assez riche en
événements politiques évidemment c'est
un magazine politique aujourd'hui sur le
premier numéro mais on l'a vraiment vu
comme un magazine avant tout
d'investigation donc bien mayenne il va
perdurer au-delà de la période politique
qui est actuellement très forte et voilà
on s'est lancé sur le
le premier numéro sur eric zemmour parce
que c'était lui qui faisait parler en ce
moment au niveau de la politique
parlez nous de la ligne éditoriale de
ces offres une ligne éditoriale un peu
un peu investigations à l'anglo saxonne
c'est sa presse le presse c'est vrai que
c'est assez original on est on est là
dans ce magazine qui font le reste est
question de vous dis là nous c'est un
magazine qui va être 100% consacrée à un
seul sujet sur chaque numéro on est dans
une période un peu speed est confuse en
même temps donc beaucoup de nous on a
envie avec ce magazine d'investigation
de prendre le temps de se poser et de
réfléchir le plus longtemps possible sur
ce sujet là donc on a lancé l' enquête
sur eric zemmour ya un bon moment demain
ce sera un autre prétendant à la
l'élection mais après demain ça peut
être aussi un magazine sur un flic
société quel genre d'équipé dit orianne
avez vous recruté quels sont les
journalistes que vous avez engagé pour
fabriquer ce magazine donc aujourd'hui
l'équipe qui fabrique le magazine au
niveau technique est à demeure à la
rédaction mais sinon à chaque numéro est
donc à chaque sujet on trouvera une
équipe d'enquêteurs le plus spécialistes
possible du sujet pour vraiment collé et
apporter à nos lecteurs en remerciement
de l'information de précision
d'éclairage vraiment pour que ils
comprennent le sujet dans cette nouvelle
idée alors la question que je me pose
est ce que c'est un magazine destiné à
l'establishment à ceux qui connaissent
la politique à ceux qui regardent ou est
ce que c'est un magazine qui est destiné
au plus grand nombre voilà tous les gens
qui habitent dans les régions en france
non c'est vraiment un magazine qu'on
veut qui doit s'adresser à tous à tout
le monde à toute la france ça magazine
qui sera dans les régions évidemment
parce que à chaque fois on va essayer de
traiter des sujets qui font le
l'événement en ce moment voilà alors ce
nouveau magazine c'est off on le trouve
où comment est il distribuait oui
aujourd'hui le magazine est évidemment
au kiosque depuis le 14 décembre donc
c'est un trimestriel à 5 0 90 et on va
être distribué dans toute la france
évidemment puisque le tirage est
quasiment à 50000 exemplaires donc voilà
ce qu'un magazine que vous pourrez
trouver partout à connexion plus cas je
l'espère dans tous les kiosques merci
nicolas aggir d'avoir été l'invité de ce
jt vous êtes le rédacteur en chef de ce
nouveau magazine politique de groupe
world media ses offres que l'on voit sur
cet écran merci à vous
voilà c'est la fin de second jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition sur vos chaînes locales et
régionales mais aussi sur tv5monde au
revoir
[Musique]